[Music]
so here with Elle Blakey here from the
wat makeer district council is one of
their counselors for the districts who
have been really supportive of this
whole project so it's great to have all
involved there's august last year now
that we set out to raise about twenty
thousand dollars for the restoration of
this section of the silver stream so
about 350 meters in total we've been
able to raise all of that which has been
awesome so we're really grateful to
everybody that gave to the project yeah
I just endorse what you've said then and
everybody watching this do come down and
have a look this this Creek is something
it's flowing at about four qmix it's
clean it's clear shingle bottom even if
you're not just we're getting involved
with the planting come and come and walk
the reserve look for the car park on
Southie Road and come and have a look
it's a beautiful bit of the country when
volunteers plant plants they feel a
sense of ownership and we want the
community to feel a sense of ownership
with this receive and just help to make
it a better place
[Music]
we're gonna have a series of planting
days starting from mid-march through to
about early May if you want to get
involved if you go to the project you'll
be able to find out more about those on
the reserve Facebook page which is
facebook.com slash silver stream reserve
you can also keep an eye on the council
website www.ge.com is a terrific asset
it's one of the highest quality lowland
streams with God and Canterbury supports
a real range of aquatic fauna as well as
be incredibly clear and it could have
been low on contaminants so it's more
important now than ever that we are
doing everything we can to particular
sorry we want to say thanks to everybody
that donated to the project and we're
incredibly grateful
[Music]